chaque jour dans cet hôpital c'est le
même problème la flux de patients qui
échoue à l'urgence forte d'accès rapide
à un médecin de famille ici une dame
âgée attend depuis des heures avec son
conjoint j'ai fait des pieds des mains
pour revenir ici j'ai un médecin famille
ça a pris trois semaines avant de le
voir
mon médecin est parti à la retraite 17
hommes partout au Québec c'est un
problème grandissant et c'est en partie
pourquoi ici le nombre de cas léger a
augmenté depuis un an et pourquoi malgré
la calmée sur le front covid la
situation se complique mais on est
revenu à la période antérieure même à
des volumes un peu plus élevés
et c'est encore plus compliqué pour les
cas lourds qui doivent être placés sur
civière on a une capacité de 46 filières
on est à 62 patients sur civière en ce
jeudi le taux d'occupation des civières
dépasse les 130%. il faut encore placer
des patients dans les corridors
le statut spécifique de chaque personne
le plus probable c'est des gens qui sont
en attente d'hospitalisation à l'étage
si les civières de l'urgence déborde
c'est parce que les autres départements
ne peuvent recevoir les patients qu'il
nécessitent comme ici en pneumologie
environ 22 patients hospitalisés en
pneumologie en commençant la semaine je
vous dirais qu'on était on avait environ
à 7 ou 8 patients qui étaient en attente
de sortie d'hôpital transfert vers un
autre centre pour la suite de leur prise
en charge donc vers des CHSLD
c'est vraiment le nerf de la guerre
trouver de l'hébergement pour les
patients AG ou encore des soins à
domicile on va transférer ça qui le
droit là pour accélérer le retour à
domicile le plus possible ok le défi est
crucial tellement que même le PDG de
l'établissement assiste à ces rencontres
matinales le cieux vient même d'ajouter
une équipe entièrement consacrée à ce
problème en transférant vers sa région
ça nous libère un lit mais en même temps
on est dans un statut d'instabilité en
attendant une solution au travail à
maintenir la force et l’autonomie des
années et ont réussi à offrir un séjour
agréable malgré la pression qui augmente
partout dans l'établissement
disponibilité et puis non ça ça regarde
bien pour les employés de l'urgence le
temps supplémentaire reste omniprésent
comme bien d'autres tiens grâce aux
dévouement du personnel on se demande
combien de temps ça pourra durer ici
David gentil les radios Canada Montréal